hey that's good booty pay
kill me please
today we're gonna do the marshmallow
challenge we're gonna play a really hard
game and to challenge myself every time
I die I'll put a mesh mallow in my mouth
it's gonna be gross it's gonna be nasty
finally not gonna be that funny but
let's give it a go I hate that stupid
give up fun in bed okay only present
source of encouragement shut up at the
[ __ ]
I don't wake it up
he's [ __ ] me y'all got lasers no big
deal can still talk ah are you kidding
me
now that doesn't count oh my god stop
please
[ __ ] okay I got this first don't
worry about it
oh my god give me a [ __ ] break
oh oh no it's okay don't worry about I
know what I'm doing
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
hold the [ __ ] on all right I got this
[ __ ] helmet is yellow Fichte
nope nope your knowing you don't know
and you're on well [ __ ] you territory
whoa
that'll leave a mark
probably the worst challenge ever I went
so fast I don't think this guy wants me
so hard I'm not giving up we're gonna do
this one more time
I have spit protection I have
marshmallows
I got marshmallows for day son okay here
we go wow I can talk the best commentary
of every day yes yes brutal Wow oh you
coward Jesus Christ mate
what how
oh god oh god oh god oh no I got an ass
with Jason okay now follow me
I gave up once it was the best thing I
ever did I strongly suggest you try it
Terry fools that was a bad one
Oh wrong time zone
what
some kind of sick game show what oh geez
that was it
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you want more challenges leave a like
and let me know if you're a bro or a
hope and I will see you as always the
next one thank you for watching and stay
on